une atmosphère calme mais sinistre
c'est dans cette ambiance que s'est
déroulée cette première journée
d'audience à la cour d'assises de nevers
à la barre cinq prévenus
quatre d'entre eux sont accusés d'avoir
séquestré et commis des violences ayant
entraîné la mort de nicolas laporte
mais en ce début de semaine difficile
encore de connaître le rôle de chacun
bien évidemment chacun va essayer de
d'envoyer les responsabilités sur les
uns ou les autres et puis il va y avoir
des minimisation de responsabilité mais
voilà il est trop tôt pour dire
actuellement quelle heure qu'est ce
qu'il en ressortira
les faits remontent à décembre 2011 à
cette époque nicolas laporte aurait été
battue et privés de nourriture par son
oncle et des proches habitent dans la
nièvre
victime de nombreux coups le jeune homme
âgé de 25 ans aurait succombé à ses
blessures au bout de quelques semaines
pour faire disparaître le corps les
bourreaux présumés aurait confectionné
un coffrage en béton jetés dans un canal
latéral à la loire a âprement sur allier
dans le cher le cadavre a été découvert
plus d'un an après pour la partie civile
on ce lundi le rappel des événements est
difficile à entendre
elle espère pouvoir trouver des réponses
ce cas dans la famille c'est que sache à
peu près cas
on n'attend pas la vérité on attend
dualité approcher ce que chacun a fait
est que chacun puisse dire exactement
quelle était son action quel était son
comportement et peut-être aussi en a
tant qu'elles sont les regrets
aujourd'hui sincères qu'ils peuvent
exprimer
c'est maintenant ou jamais 18 témoins
sont attendus à la barre durant la
semaine pour éclaircir cette affaire
cette première journée a été consacrée
en partie à dresser la personnalité de
chacun des accusés
quatre des prévenus encourent la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
le cinquième qui a aidé à transporter le
corps risque deux ans de prison